we have peace been discussing in this
forum how we could expand the frontiers
of innovation between Central Europe and
Central Asia I think this is a wonderful
issue to discuss about and from my point
of view if you have a look between the
region of Europe and Central Asia you
will see a lot of diversity but I think
if you have a more detailed look in both
regions you will see within this
diversity there are a lot of chances
because we are as Europeans living in
the aging society Central Asia this is a
real another story we don't have so much
resources but there are a lot of
resources or you gas mining with all
different kinds in Central Asia and so I
think we could exchange views we could
exchange our employees we could see what
we could do in this region working
together because if they have resources
and we don't if we have experienced
people and people which have a lot of
expertise in innovation and you need
that of course this could create a
win-win situation for both regions I
hope that we will have as an outcome of
this conference that we have a more
concrete look on opportunities what we
could do together in future and if we
cooperate very close I think we will
reach a lot of success within the next
year's